later in the show I'm gonna have clips
for you of Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson who almost certainly has been
vaccinated for a really long time uh
spreading the debunked unsubstantiated
claim
that vaccines might be killing thousands
of people now I've been getting calls
from people for a year at this point or
uh not no not quite that's an exact
eight months or so
saying David the coveted vaccine is
killing people this has been floating
around for a while but it's really
growing now
um just as one it's mostly happening on
Facebook but just as a reminder here's
video we looked at last week this was
the uh Gavin Newsom Joe Biden rally the
day before the California recall this is
the California recall last Tuesday which
went horribly wrong for republicans and
you've got to listen closely but one of
the arguments happening outside was with
a woman claiming that more people died
from the covet vaccine than from the flu
take a listen to this
so just give it time remember the woman
on the right is the woman arguing about
the economy Air Force mom in the blue
shirt is the one spreading the vaccine
death conspiracies it's gonna focus in
on her in a moment
quite a day
and the these audio problems are in the
clip I apologize
[Music]
unless people die from the flu
vaccine in one year have you looked it
up okay so this is getting a lot of
attention and it's important to remind
you that there is no evidence that
people are dying from the vaccine so
PolitiFact
um Flags this as having sort of started
with Facebook posts on August 24th it's
older than that but okay for the
purposes of today uh the claim was
hundreds of thousands died after taking
the advice of these celebrities who were
aiding and abetting mass murder By
advocating vaccination now the if your
time is short summary
from PolitiFact Is there is no evidence
of coveted vaccines causing deaths
according to the CDC there is no
evidence that covid-19 vaccines have
caused any deaths in the United States
this was then updated
um there is a 24-minute video slamming
celebrities for recommending the
vaccines says the vaccines have killed
hundreds of thousands of people the text
at the start of the video says quote you
may never trust another celebrity after
watching this video hundreds of
thousands died after taking the advice
of these celebrities should they be
tried for murder aiding and abetting
mass murder through vaccination all for
population control Facebook did
ultimately take that down
um and as the article points out covet
has killed nearly 675 000 in the U.S and
more than four and a half million
worldwide the vaccines authorized in the
U.S have been shown to significantly
reduce the likelihood of severe illness
hospitalization and death and no
evidence has established that a covid-19
vaccine authorized in the U.S has caused
any deaths let alone hundreds of
thousands I think it's important to be
precise there we really don't know
what's going on with some of these other
vaccines in other countries they haven't
been evaluated by the American FDA and
the reporting around their side effects
is is you know incomplete at best so
we're not saying anything one way or the
other I have no reason to think the
Russian vaccine or the Chinese vaccine
or killing people I have family in
Argentina that have gotten those
vaccines the article though is being
specific and precise
saying the vaccines authorized in the
United States
uh we have no evidence to suggest that
those are killing people so
unfortunately you know when the
situation escalates the conspiracy
theories seem to escalate as well and
now they're just straight up saying
hundreds of thousands Dead from the
vaccines without any evidence whatsoever
later in the show we are going to talk
about Tucker Carlson signal boosting
this false claim and we're going to talk
about how easy it is I I didn't do it
but I went through and started going
through the process to see how easy it
is it is so easy to submit a false
vaccine side effect claim up to and
including death in What's called the
vares system v-a-e-r-s that you may well
have reports of deaths that are
unsubstantiated as well so we're going
to get to that a little bit later if you
know people in your personal life who
are who are repeating this one thousands
dead hundreds of thousands Dead from the
vaccines I want to hear from you okay
find me on Twitter at dpacman or shoot
us an email info davidpackman.com